ich finde es ist in der derzeitigen
situation es steht halt nicht jeder zu
hause und bauten flipchart auf und hat
einen sohn konferenz sondern das gros
der menschen sitzt in der kasse am band
wie frau gerne auch gerade richtig sagte
den nützt home office überhaupt gar
nichts und selbst na ich sitze zu hause
mit drei kindern also und einem
anschuldigung der solle nicht vergessen
seine aber also nichtsdestotrotz wir
streiten uns darum wer arbeiten gehen
darf ja also wer wäre vorschlägt home
office gesetzlich zu verankern hat also
für für und damit familien zu entlasten
hat weder verstanden was es bedeutet
kinder zu betreuen
noch hat verstanden was es bedeutet zu
arbeiten und dass das eben ohne hilfe
nicht zusammengeht und er hilft ja auch
kein gesetz wie der arbeitslose wurden
[Musik]